PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video what
we'd like to do
is to solve a certain
differential equation.
And I'm not even giving
you initial condition.
So we just want to find a
y, such that x times dy/dx
is equal to x squared plus
x times y squared plus 1.
So I'll give you a
minute to think about it
and then I'll be back.
Welcome back.
I'm going to use the technique
of separation of variables
to solve this differential
equation problem.
Hopefully you thought
about doing that as well.
Because it's really
set up nicely
for separation of variables.
So let me let me first
get all of the values,
or terms that involve y
on the left-hand side.
And then I'm going to move
the dx to the right-hand side
and get all the
terms that involve
x to the right-hand side.
So I'm going to
write dy divided by y
squared plus 1 is equal to-- so
I'm going to multiply through
by dx divided by x.
So I'm going to get x
squared plus x over x dx.
Now if x is 0, I
have a little problem
but we're going to ignore
that for the moment.
So I can rewrite
this as x plus 1 dx.
And now I'm totally set
up with my next step
in separation of variables and
so I can integrate both sides.
So let's see what happens when
I integrate the left-hand side.
OK?
What is an antiderivative
to 1 over y squared plus 1?
Well that's arctangent,
that's arctangent of y.
So the derivative
of arctangent of y
is 1 over y squared plus 1.
And so on the left-hand
side I get arctan y.
If you wrote tangent
to the minus 1 y,
that's the same thing,
the inverse tangent of y,
that's the same thing.
And on the right-hand
side what do I get?
Well this is a nice
easy thing to integrate.
When I integrate x, I
get x squared over 2.
And here I just get an x.
And then I should
add in my constants.
So x squared over 2
plus x plus a constant.
So this is, so far I'm
doing everything OK.
Now I need to figure out
how to isolate the y.
Well arctan y is the inverse
of the tangent function.
So if I want to isolate
y I have to take
the tangent of both sides.
So when I take tangent of
arctangent of y I just get y.
Then over here, I get tangent of
x squared over 2 plus x plus C.
And now because I didn't give
you any initial conditions,
we can't say anything
about C. But if I gave you
some initial conditions then we
could evaluate and solve for C.
Now how do I go about checking
to make sure that this works?
Well, what I do is actually
take the derivative.
So you may want to
take the derivative
of the right-hand
side, take dy/dx.
Evaluate what that
is when you have y
equals tangent of x squared
over 2 plus x plus C
and see if you in fact get
the relationship you're
supposed to get.
But I'll stop there.